Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one seven area code.
Who's calling today from nine one seven?
Hey, David.
This is Sam.
Hey, Sam, what's going on?
So I'm right now I'm 19 years old and I try
to engage with a lot of my friends and talking
about political activism and stuff.
But I feel like that the only thing that they
could talk about is the Instagram stories
that they are reposting.
And I can't really have educated discussions
with my friends because all they do is post
stuff on our Instagram stories of just headlines
with no real explanation or education, for
that matter, just words.
So I'm I'm having trouble engaging with my
friends.
And I've actually suggested your YouTube channel.
And I'm just wondering, like, what is the
best way to engage with these Instagram activists
in real change besides posting something on
their Instagram stories?
So you when you say that they're posting Instagram
stories, their Instagram stories related to
news and politics, but they're just basically
regurgitating headlines and not really diving
into the substance, it sounds like you're
saying.
Exactly.
And are they people who are aligned with you
politically or not aligned with you politically?
Yeah.
Align with me politically.
And usually people who are posting stuff for
black lives matter for a Biden administration.
But the way they do it is they're just posting
straight headlines with no real information
or articles supporting their ideas.
So what I would ask in an empathetic way.
And so the good thing is you're not trying
to change anyone's mind here.
These are already people who are on your side
politically.
You're just trying to get them to be better
activists.
And so a couple different things.
One, check out my interviews about political
hobby ism.
I've done a couple of them which talks about
exactly this issue, which is following the
news and retweeting or posting stuff to Instagram.
It's political hobby ism.
It's not really activism.
So first, I would check out those two interviews
to kind of understand the problem.
Then I would consider going to them and saying,
what is it you would like people to do when
they see you post these stories?
Like, clearly you're posting it because you
think it's important and you're posting it
because you want other people to see it.
What do you envision other people should be
doing and whatever it is they imagine other
people should be doing?
That's probably what they should be doing
themselves.
Right.
So if they were to say, well, I posted so
that other people will get out there and be
in touch with their elected officials or run
for local office in order to make change.
Well, you could do that instead of just posting
to Instagram.
Right.
So I would I would let them tell you what
what action they think would be most useful
and then challenge them to go and do it themselves.
All right.
Thank you so much, David.
All right, Sam, thank you.
Appreciate the phone call.